dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here what our
hilbert curves hilbert curves are
repeating lines that are used to fill a
square such curves so far have enjoyed
applications like drawing zigzag
patterns to prevent biting in our tale
in a snake game or jokes aside it is
also useful in for instance choosing the
right pixels to start tracing rays of
light in light simulations or to create
good strategies in assigning numbers to
different computers in a network these
members by the way we call IP addresses
these are just a few examples and they
show quite well how a seemingly
innocuous mathematical structure can see
applications in the most mind-bending
ways imaginable so here's one more
actually two more Fermat's spiral is
essentially a long line as a collection
of low curvature spirals these are
generated by a remarkably simple
mathematical expression and we can also
observe such shapes in Mother Nature for
instance in a sunflower and the most
natural question emerges in the head of
every seasoned fellow scholar why is
that why would nature be following
mathematics or anything to do with what
Fermat wrote on a piece of paper once it
has only been relatively recently shown
that as the seeds are growing in the
sunflower they exert forces on each
other therefore they cannot be arranged
in an arbitrary way we can write up the
mathematical equations to look for a way
to maximize the concentration of growth
hormones within the plant to make it as
resilient as possible in the meantime
this force exertion constraint has to be
taken into consideration if we solve
this equation with blood sweat and tears
we may experience some moments of great
peril but it will be all washed away by
the beautiful site of this arrangement
this is exactly what we see in nature
and which happens to be almost exactly
the same as a mind-bendingly simple
Fermat spiral pattern
words fail me to describe how amazing it
is that mother nature is essentially
able to find these solutions by herself
really cool isn't it if our mind wasn't
blown enough yet Fermat spirals can also
be used to approximate a number of
different shapes with the added
constraint that we start from a given
point take an enormous Li long journey
of low curvature shapes and get back to
almost exactly where we started this
again sounds like an innocuous little
game evoking ill-concealed laughter in
the audience as it is presented by as
excited as underpaid mathematicians
however as always this is not the case
at all researchers have found that if we
get a 3d printing machine and create a
layered material exactly like this the
surface will have a higher degree of
fairness be quicker to print and will be
generally of higher quality than other
possible shapes if we think about it if
we wish to print a proscribed object
like this cat there is a stupendously
large number of ways to fill this space
with curves that eventually form a cat
and if we do it with Fermat spirals it
will yield the highest quality print one
can do at this point in time in the
paper this is demonstrated for a number
of shapes of varying complexities and
this is what research is all about
finding interesting connections between
different fields that are not only
beautiful but also enrich our everyday
lives with useful inventions in the
meantime we have reached our first
milestone on patreon and I am really
grateful to you fellow scholars who are
really passionate about supporting the
show we are growing at an extremely
rapid pace and I am really excited to
make even more episodes about these
amazing research works thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time